من ينقذ السودان المعارك في شهرها الثالث
ولا افق للحسد فلم يتبقى في السودان
الكثير البنوك نهبت المواطن من قتلوا كل
المنازل سرقت هناك عنف غير مبرر وعنف ضد
النساء هذا هو الحال كما وصفه مالك عقار
نائب رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني اما
الامين العام للامم المتحده انطونيو
بوتيرج فقال ان السودان يغرق في الموت
والدمار بسرعه غير مسبوقه وحذر رئيس
مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي من امكانيه
انزلاق البلاد الى حرب اهليه وانتيار
الدوله
[موسيقى]
من القاعده الاعلى للقوات المسلحه
بمهام محدده مهام الدعم السريع اسناد
الجيش بعيدا الدعم السريع بشكل اخر هو جزء
من القوات المسلحه في السودان كل حمايه
ولايه الخرطوم كانت
الدعم السري رفض قائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان دقلو المشاركه في مجلس ابن عوف
لكنه سرعان ما وافق في الثالثه عشر من
ابريل على المشاركه في مجلس البرهان اثر
ترقيته الى رتبه فريق اول وتعيينه نائبا
له ليصبح الشخص الثاني في المجلس
استمر الاعتصام مبنى القياده العامه للجيش
السوداني بسبب مطالب الشارع الثوره
السوداني بحكم مدني بخروج المؤسسه
العسكريه بعوده الجيش الى السكنات
في الثالث من يونيو فضه قوات عسكريه
اعتصام القياده العامه مخلفه عددا من
القتلى والمفقودين
[موسيقى]
كلنا عشان نوصل ازار العمل
باذن الله
طبيعه العلاقه بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
فتره فضل كانت على اعلى درجاتها
كان
قائد الدعم السريع جزء من اتخاذ القرار
وكان في اتجاه من المجلس العسكري هو
الانفراد بالحكم حينها كانوا هم متوافقين
وتم اختيار عبد الله حمدوك رئيسا للوزراء
رغم من الاتفاق على حكومه مدنيه ظل المكون
العسكري المتمثل في مجلس السياده يمارس
ادوارا سياسيه مختلفه حيث تراس احمد قياده
مفاوضات السلام في جنوب السودان واللجنه
العليا لاداره الازمات الاقتصاديه واللجنه
العليا لجمع السلاح بجانب عضويته في مجلس
شركاء الفتره الانتقاليه منصب نائب رئيس
مجلس
سياسيه اصلا بدات تزايد المضطرد لنفوذ
قوات الدعم السريع عقب اجتذابه لبعض ضباط
الجيش للخدمه في صفوفه
العاليه هي كانت سبب في التحاق الضباط
والجنود كان في غيرها يعني جندي في في
الدعم السريع بياخد اربع اضعاف الجندي في
القوات المسلحه امتيازات واسعه ضباط
امتيازات واسعه ومع صدور قرار بحل هيئه
العمليات التابعه لجهاز المخابرات والامن
في عام 2020 بدات سيطره الدعم السريع على
معسكراتها وعتادها بالضباط القوات المسلحه
متزمرين كيف انت تحل هيئه العمليات متسلبه
كل مواقع هيئه تسلم
في اكثر من 40 دبابه استلمها والقوات
المسلحه والدعم السريع حاجه واحده الناس
شغاله اشاعات
اصلاح القطاع الامني والعسكري والشروع في
الو
صول وقومي ودي مهمه لازم تدعمي حاول حمدوك
اصلاح القطاع العسكري والامني من خلال
مبادره الطريق الى الامام لكن رفض الدعم
السريع دمج قواته في الجيش السوداني احدث
عقبه في مسار الانتقال السياسي في البلاد
وكانت تلك اولى مظاهر الخلاف بين الجيش
والدعم السريع انني قد قررت
ان ارد اليكم امانتكم
واعلن لكم
استقالتي متفقين في الانقلاب وشارك حماتي
بقواته شارك بيت امين وممارسات سياسيه
خاطئه
ادت الى ما حدث في 25 اكتوبر محمد حمدان
ويعتبروا هو حل
لندامته عن انقلاب 25 اكتوبر الاتفاق
الاطار ادى الى الجيش الدعم السريع في
قضيه اساسيه انه جعل انه الجيش والدعم
السريع يكونوا متوازيين او في كفه واحده
كانت ورشه الاصلاح الامني والعسكري اخر
المحاولات السلميه للخروج بالتوافق بين
المكونين العسكريين دعوه سريع اصر على
ايقونه على مدى عشر سنوات واعلن انه يمكن
ان يوافق عن التنبيه من خلال ثلاث مقترحات
احاله حوالي 800 ضابط مسلحه
وزير الداخليه ثم الموافقه على انشاء
قاعده
في استعدادات قبل فتره البرهان طلع دبابات
في الشارع سيارات درون
حشد الدعم السريع بدايه من فبراير 2023
قرابه الثلاثين الف مقاتل اضافي بجوار
قواته داخل الخرطوم
كانت سكن عسكريه وجود للدم السريع
مبالغ فيه
تزداد مخاطره بقيام قياده قوات الدعم
السريع بتحشيد القوات والانفتاح داخل
العظم
في السودان بين الجيش وقوه الدعم السريع
الخامسه من ابريل 2023
افاقت الخرطوم على وقع مواجهات بين قوات
الجيش والدعم السريع نشا من هذا تزمر
مشروع من الهامش اتخذ ادوات مختلفه يعني
انتهى في الاخر الى انه لا يمكن حل اي
مساله بغير الرفع السلاح فالمبادرات الان
تنجح اين القوه الوطنيه السياسيه اين هي
الان الان قتال بين مؤسستان عسكريتين وبين
جنرى عليه